hey guys i'm off the grid for august but  here's a generic intro to a clip we  wanted to show you  we are coming up on this one year  anniversary of the us withdrawal from  afghanistan and the taliban takeover of  that country  um you said at the time of the  withdrawal that that you would have  liked the military to stay on as long as  necessary to get americans out and  fulfill our obligation to our allies you  had pledged vigorous oversight we  haven't seen the white house or state  department after action reports on this  the country is just in utter devastation  under taliban rule  did it really have to be this bad  well i certainly don't think the  withdrawal had to  go as it did and the loss of american  lives during that withdrawal  and the degree to which it took months  and months and we continue to try to  help people escape from afghanistan i  think could have been handled  differently